le public vous surnomme l'avocat
terroriste que répondez vous à ça
et bien quand je défends une personne
accusée de viol personne ne me surnomme
l'avocat curieuse parce que je défends
une personne accusée de meurtre ou bien
pas creuser dans mon jardin et
lorsqu'une personne est accusée de
terrorisme les gens comme vous semble
pour que ces différentes tu veux
représenter la tête pensante du 11
septembre dans notre constitution il n'y
a pas d' * sur différentes modalités
d'application
ils sont venus kidnapper chez moi et
m'ont amené ici avec un sac sur la tête
et des chaînes autour de mon corps
pourquoi vous écris ton en trois ans n'y
a pas eu de charges justice expéditive
c'est ce que notre administration
réclame on va réclamer la peine de mort
et si vous vous trompiez vous avez bâti
cette prison avait abandonné tous vos
principes tout ce qui régit vos lois et
si vous aviez tort
il faut me raconter ce qui s'est passé
sinon je peux pas vous défendre mes
ravisseurs ne peuvent pas me pardonner
pour quelque chose que je n'ai pas fait
peut-être qu'il est coupable
quelqu'un doit rendre des comptes pour
ça quelqu'un
tél
arabe le mambourg libre est le mot pour
par dont celle même j'ai envie de
pardonner
c'est pour ça que même ici je peux être
libre
[Musique]